so let me ask you a question when it
comes down to hiring somebody what's
more important to you somebody you trust
a hundred percent
or somebody who is very specialized in
their skill maybe one of the best to do
it but you can only choose between trust
and skill or somebody who's got very
good soft skills but terrible hard
skills which one do you value more we're
going to process that in today's episode
[Music]
so stick around to ovarian i'm going to
give you a infographic for you to take a
look at to help you with this decision
making process so
soft skill hard skill okay
soft
here
hard skill is on this side and here's
what i mean by hard skill hard skill is
somebody that knows a very specialized
skill so if it's coding they know how to
code if it's editing they know how to
edit if it's selling they know how to
sell if it's processing they know how to
process but it's hard skill it's very
specific skill that requires technical
expertise so imagine here on this chart
to the left the higher you are the more
of an expert you are in this skill set
so this is an expert this is an amateur
but then soft skill here the higher you
are
the better you are with people the
better of a teammate you are the better
attitude you have the better
communicator you are the better eq you
have you understand what it is to work
with other people you can deal with
multiple different personalities
somebody who's very quiet and timid
somebody who's very loud and charismatic
you know how to work with everybody
because you have soft skills which of
these do you value the most so if we
were to break this down and if we were
to look at this like this is a level one
and this is a level seven ten here and
this is a level one and sub and this is
somebody who's ten here this would be
your superstar okay
so you wanna make a note of people that
you have on your team right now that are
superstars highly expert in what they're
doing but incredible with people
personalities attitude reliable all of
that together the least here would be
somebody in this category you don't
trust them they don't they don't have
their best personality best attitude
they also don't have specialized skill
set this the longer you wait to keep
these folks with your company the more
they're going to convert other people
and hold your company back you have to
be able to move on from folks in this
category as soon as possible by the way
some people might say well this is kind
of cold this is not cool why would you
do something like this because you don't
offer soft skill nor hearts because
somebody has to bring something to the
table right that's what they have to do
this is a competitive environment this
is how work works now let me continue
let me take you and give you a complete
different example this year i saw simon
sinek
example that he talked about how the
navy seal value their running mates
while they're going out there to war the
example he gave he explained trust and
specialized skill so now ask this
question from yourself
which do you value more
somebody you trust a lot
or somebody that has a very high
specialized skill so what if somebody's
an expert but you don't trust them what
if somebody is someone you trust but
they have no clue what they're doing
obviously this also becomes a superstar
and this becomes problematic because you
don't trust them nor do they have a
specialized skill set and what's even
worse is people here who are lukewarm
you don't know where they are they're
okay you trust them a little bit but not
fully they have some skill set but not
fully so you don't really know what
they're doing there makes sense you want
to be able to have people that are as
high trusting as possible and know what
they're doing again the more people you
have in this category i guarantee if you
said i got five 10 15 people in this
category you're crushing it with this
company with your company
but if you're watching this video saying
pat i got nobody in this category it's
zero you have a problem you got to be
able to go find people like this to have
them in this category because great
companies are built by people here so
now if we go back up this is the chart
that i was talking to you about in
regards to trust and performance the top
right is who high performing high trust
the middle right is what humid
performing high trust the bottom right
is what low performing high trust and if
you look at the top left high performing
low trust take inventory of the people
you have in your organization and talk
about this with your employees i had a
meeting
what was it three weeks ago in the
backyard was it three or four weeks go
advice i don't know what it was three or
four weeks ago and i broke this whole
thing down with everybody to explain to
them listen
some of you are here you don't have a
specialized skill but we trust you
you're forgiven when you're trusted by
people when people trust you they're
more patient with you to grow when you
have a specialized skill and people
don't trust you company has to be very
careful with that person you almost have
to work have them work independently
let's just say you get a full-on genius
of a person that's the best coder but
horrible with people terrible
personality what do you do with this
person you almost got to put them
working by themselves where they don't
go out there and rub anybody else the
wrong way and get that negative
personality go there let's just say
they're the best of the best of the best
in the marketplace totally fine if
you're willing to tolerate that but i
have to explain to some folks some of
you guys got great attitudes some of you
have high trust some of you are very
reliable some of you come in with great
attitudes some of you guys are coachable
you're willing to constantly improve the
market is going to favor you because the
market market today
favors soft skill favors great attitude
favors high trust favors reliability
favors people who show up favors people
who want to be a great teammate the
market is constantly going to forgive
you until eventually one day you become
a player it's just a matter of time
before you become a player so again i
don't have an exact answer for you here
you make a decision what type of people
you want to hire i just gave you what
approach i take if you want today's
message i gave you the infographic to
print out click on a link over here to
go get the print out of this infographic
and if you want to watch another video
on this that i go very very detailed and
technical is how to find a running mate
as an entrepreneur if you've never
watched this video
it's one of the best videos we've ever
put together on this specific topic
click here to watch the video take
everybody bye
[Music]